Hallo, Guten Abend.
Guten Abend.
Mein Name ist Jüngör.
Ich bin heute auf dieser Station Diasthabende.
Und für die zuständige Arzt.
Ich würde gerne mit Ihnen eine annämmliche Gespräche führen.
Sind Sie damit einfach einverstanden?
Ja, klar.
Okay.
Was für Beschwerden haben Sie?
Seit heute habe ich akute Schmerzen in meinem Rücken.
Der in meinem rechten Becken reinzieht.
Sehr starke Schmerzen.
Seit heute Morgen, oder?
Ja, seit heute Morgen, kann man sagen.
Wir können.
Okay.
Sind diese Schmerzen irgendwo ausstrahlen?
Ja, die strahlen in meinem Becken aus.
Die sind irgendwo in meiner Lendenwirbelsäule.
Und strahlt in meinem Becken aus.
Rechte Seite.
Könnten Sie bitte diese Schmerzen beschreiben?
Wie soll ich das beschreiben?
Es ist ein sehr starker Schmerz.
Der stechend ist, würde ich eher sagen.
Ein stechender Schmerz.
Wie stark sind diese Schmerzen auf einer Skala,
wobei 0 ohne Schmerzen ist,
die Schmerzen sind sehr stark.
Ja, es kommt und geht.
Wenn es gut ist, dann habe ich 8.
Wenn es nicht gut ist, dann habe ich 12.
Das ist manchmal sehr schlimm.
Ja, okay.
Jetzt acht, oder?
Seit heute ist es acht, ja.
Es geht gerade.
Können Sie bis Ende Gespräche aushalten, oder?
Ja, ich lange dort.
Wie heißen Sie denn?
Mein Name ist Werner Baumann.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 66 Jahre alt.
Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,70 m groß ungefähr.
Wie wiegen Sie?
95 kg.
Entschuldigung, Könnten Sie bitte wiederholen?
Okay, ich verstehe.
Wie heißt Ihr Hausarzt?
Mein Hausarzt ist Dr. Walter.
Okay, Herr Baumann.
Sie haben seit heute Morgen
rechten Beckenschmerzen.
Wie soll das Schmerz?
Lein der Schmerzen.
Und strahlen in den rechten Becken.
Ja, genau.
Ich verstehe.
Sind diese Schmerzen erst mal aufgetreten?
Ja, das habe ich erst einmal.
Ich hatte so etwas nicht vorher gehabt.
Sind diese Schmerzen in den Oberchenkel ausstrahlen?
Nein.
Oder Beine?
Nein, in die Beine.
In meinen Becken.
Ich verstehe.
Und haben Sie in Ihrem Becken
oder in Ihrer Beine
eine Taubheit gefühlt?
Schwindelig?
Schwäche?
Schwäche, wo?
Also Taubheit habe ich nicht.
Schwindelig ist mir auch nicht.
Was meinen Sie mit Schwäche?
Schwäche, ja.
Das ist zum Beispiel,
dass man Schwierigkeit beim Laufen kann.
Beim Laufen, also in den Beinen Schwäche habe ich nichts.
Okay.
Ich verstehe.
Und haben Sie Probleme
mit Wasserlassen oder Stuhlgang?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Haben Sie Brennen oder Schmerzhaft?
Schmerzhaft ist bei den Brennen Wasserlassen auch nicht.
Okay.
Und wann ist die Kontenz,
diese Schmerzen ganz genau bezeichnen?
Sind diese Schmerzen dauerhaft?
Die gehende Kommande,
das ist ein dauerhafter Schmerz,
aber der manchmal schlimmer und manchmal weniger schlimmer ist.
Aber ein dauerhafter Schmerz.
Bauchschmerzen?
Bauchschmerzen habe ich nicht.
Haben Sie Schwellung
oder in dem Bauchbereich?
Schwellung.
Bauchbereich habe ich keine Schwellung, nein. Also nicht bemerkt.
Haben Sie eingeschränkte Bewegung?
Ja, meine Lendenbibelsäule, das ist sehr eingeschränkt.
Ich kann mich nicht richtig bewegen.
Bewegung haben Sie nicht mehr, sagen Sie?
Ja, bei Bewegung,
wenn ich aufstehen möchte, wenn ich nach vorne bücken will, geht nicht.
Nur bei bestimmten Positionen kann ich noch ein bisschen,
wenn ich mich nicht bewege,
beim Sitzen oder beim Entliegen,
da geht es noch ein bisschen, aber
das ist ein dauerhafter Schmerz.
Haben Ihre Schmerzen bei Bewegung verstärkt?
Ja, bei Schmerzen sind Bewegungsabhängige zunehmend.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Und haben Sie ab?
Ja, ich habe Ihnen aufgefallen,
dass Sie heute Morgen sehr belastbare Arbeit suchen?
Nein, ich bin heute Morgen aufgestanden.
Ich bin selber Rentner, ich arbeite nicht.
Und es ist dann halt vorm Tagsendwann begonnen.
Ich habe mich nach vorne gebückt und wollte etwas heben.
Das war ein leerer Wäschekorb, der war nicht voll.
Und dann ist es passiert.
Also nicht schwindelig.
Sind diese Schmerzen plötsch aufgetreten?
Ja, genau.
Haben Sie Schlachtprobleme?
Nein, aber heute Nacht kann ich bestimmt nicht schlafen wegen den Schmerzen.
Heute, oder?
Ja, ich denke, Sie helfen mir, dass ich schlafen kann.
Dass die Schmerzen weniger werden.
Okay, ich habe Ihnen aufgefallen,
in der letzten Zeit sehr viel abzunehmen oder so genommen.
Gewichtszunahme oder Abnahme?
Nein, ich habe ungefähr seit Monaten in der gleichen Gewichtsklasse.
Haben Sie irgendeine Bereitschallergie?
Allergien? Ja, ich habe eine Pelezylin Allergie.
Gehen Sie nicht mit der Habenzialergie?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Nur Penicillin?
Haben Sie Unverträglichkeit gegen etwas oder Ernährung?
Ja, also ich muss immer achten, dass ich Milchprodukte nacktosefrei esse.
Deswegen trinken Sie sehr wenig Milch?
Ja, aber ich kaufe schon Milch, aber ich lege nacktosefrei Milch.
Damit komme ich gut zurecht.
Brauchen Sie?
Ja, ich brauche.
Seit wann?
20 Jahre, kann man sagen.
Ja, 20 Jahre, kann man sagen.
Wie viel?
Ja, so eine Packung Zigarette am Tag.
Brauche ich schon, ja.
Okay, das ist vieler.
Ich kann Ihnen empfehlen, diese Gewohnheit so verlassen.
Ja, aber irgendeine Sünde muss ja einen Mensch haben.
Ja, und trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, nicht regelmäßig.
Ab und zu zum Essen trinke ich mal ein Glas Wein, sonst nicht.
Man gönnt sich ja sonst nichts.
Aber jeden Tag?
Nein, nicht jeden Tag.
Vielleicht zwei, drei Mal die Woche, abends ein Glas Wein.
Kommt drauf an, was meine Bau für Essen macht oder was ich koche.
Dass meine Frau kocht und manchmal passt ein Wein dazu.
Oder wenn wir zum Restaurant gehen, nicht regelmäßig haben.
Feiern nicht, sondern weil es Gelegenheiten ist.
Also zwei, drei Mal die Woche ein Glas Wein.
Okay, okay.
Bitte nehmen Sie diese Frage nicht persönlich.
Das ist eine rundwiener Frage.
Haben Sie Kontakt mit Drogen?
Ich weiß noch nicht mal, wie Drogen geschrieben wird.
Nein.
Haben Sie, ja, könnten Sie bitte mir sagen,
dass Sie, ob Sie irgendwelche Vorerkrankungen
oder chronische Erkrankungen haben?
Also, ich nehme regelmäßig Medikamente ein,
wegen Bluthochdruck.
Welche Medikamente?
Wer hat eine Familie?
Wer hat eine Familie? 80 Milligramm?
80 Milligramm, Wongs und abends eine Tablette.
Nehmen Sie noch andere Medikamente ein?
Regelmäßig.
Regelmäßig nicht. Doch, ISS 100.
Mein Hausarzt hat mir gesagt, dass ich vorbeuglich das nehmen sollte.
Vorsorglich.
Okay, wer hat eine Medikamente?
ISS 100.
Aber Sie haben keine chronische Herzkrankheit?
Herzkrankheit, Gott sei Dank nicht.
Nicht, dass ich wüsste.
Ich wüsste aber zu einem Kardilogen gehen, weiß ich nicht.
Das letzte Mal war vor zehn Jahren, war alles okay gewesen.
Okay.
Außer Bluthochdruck haben Sie keine chronische Krankheit.
Ich weiß nicht, ich hoffe nicht.
Okay.
Und, wo haben Sie schon operiert?
Ja, in meiner Kindheit wurde ich operiert, aber ich bin 15 Jahre alt.
Am Blindam wurde ich operiert.
Am Blindam.
Ist Ihr Blutblutdruck raus?
Ja, genau.
Es wurde entfernt.
Damals.
Wo ich jung und knackig war.
Ja.
Und, hatten Sie in dieser Operation irgendwelche Komplikationen
oder Prokuren?
Ja, damals.
Ja, also ich habe Penicillin allergie,
weil sie hatten bei der OP Penicillin gegeben.
Und auch während der OP Zeit, so genau weiß ich nicht mehr,
da hatte ich gegen Penicillin ein allergeschreagiert.
Okay.
Bei der Operation?
Ja, ich weiß nicht mehr, ob das jetzt während der Operation
oder ich weiß nur, dass ich Penicillin allergie habe seit der OP.
Okay.
Und ich möchte über Ihre Familie Gäste fragen.
Und Leben Ihrer Eltern?
Mein Eltern leben nicht mehr, nein.
Und warum?
Was die gestorben?
Ihre Eltern gestorben.
Mein Vater hatte einen Herzinfarkt.
Damals war er 72 Jahre alt.
Und meine Mutter hatte einen Schlaganfall gehabt.
Schlaganfall.
Und an den Folgen vor Schlaganfall war sie verstorben.
Damals war sie 78 Jahre alt.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Ja, ich habe ein Bruder.
Ist Ihr Bruder gesund?
Ja, ich denke schon.
Aber er nimmt auch Medikamenten.
Ich weiß nur, dass er wegen Bluthochdruck nimmt
und wegen Schilddröse was nimmt.
Sonst weiß ich nicht.
Aber warum?
Weshalb weiß ich nicht.
Hab ich mal so gehabt.
Ja, per Stamm.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ich bin verheiratet, ja.
Leben Sie zusammen?
Ja, genau.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, ich habe zwei Kinder.
Sind Ihr Kinder gesund?
Soweit ich weiß, ja.
Gut, danke.
Sind Sie jetzt Rentner?
Genau.
Welche Beruf haben Sie geübt?
Ausgeübt, vorher.
Ich war in der IT-Branche.
Haben Sie momentan Stress?
Bei der Familienleben?
Nein, eigentlich nicht.
Nur jetzt habe ich Stress wegen den Schmerzen.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Ich habe meine Fragen beendet.
Haben Sie mich gefragt?
Herr Doktor, wie geht es weiter?
Was habe ich denn?
Was denken Sie?
Ich vermute, dass Sie einen Bandscheibenvorfall haben.
Wir müssen erst einmal untersuchen.
Danach müssen wir einige Bildgebende durchführen.
Okay.
Ich werde erst einmal durchführen.
Ich werde von Ihnen Blut abnehmen.
Ich werde überprüfen.
Was ist das für eine CT oder MRT?
Es ist gefährlich.
Es ist eng.
Ich habe Platzangst.
Ich kann nicht in engen Bäumen sein.
Die Computer-Tomographie hat eine Strahlung.
Wenn Sie sagen Strahlung?
Das ist ein Radio-Röntgenstrahlung.
Ist das gefährlich?
Nein, das ist nicht gefährlich.
Wir führen täglich viele Mal durch für unsere Patienten.
Das ist nicht gefährlich.
Aber es entsteht eine Strahlung.
MRT ist ein Bildgebende-Verfahren.
Was ist das Unterschied zwischen MRT und CT?
Es ist besser, weil MRT keine Strahlung gibt.
Es ist eine enge Röhrung.
Es ist eng.
Es gibt genug Platz.
Sie können Musik hören.
Aber MRT hat genug Platz.
Sie haben recht.
Sie können ruhig hören.
Sie wollen mit Medikamenten beruhigen?
Es ist notwendig.
Dankeschön.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Hatten Sie einen Unfall oder eine Verletzung?
Nein, ich habe nicht.
Ich habe auch eine Frage.
Haben Sie Fieber, Nachtschweiß oder Schüttelfrost in letzter Zeit gehabt?
Nein, ich habe nicht gehabt.
Was ist das für eine Allergie?
Ich hatte eine Atemnot und Schwellung im Halsbereich.
Sind Ihnen Lehmungen aufgefallen?
Nein.
Wie äußert sich die Unfall-Unfall?
Ich bekomme Bauchschmerzen.
Ich bekomme auch Durchfall.
Haben Sie einen Schmerz mit Lein genommen?
Ich habe einen Profil genommen.
Ich habe 600 Milligramm gebraucht.
Ich habe die Schmerz leicht gelindert.
Aber nur für 2 Stunden war es nicht sehr hilfreich.
Ich habe die Ersatzgeschichte begonnen.
Ich habe heute einen neuen Patil.
Ihr Name ist nochmal?
Herr Günger, mein Name.
Herr Günger, Sie sind neu hier in der Ambulanz.
Bitte schön, legen Sie los.
Ich habe heute einen neuen Patient aufgenommen.
Ich würde gerne Ihnen vorstellen.
Haben Sie dafür seid?
Gerne.
Herr Baumann ist 66 Jahre alt.
Er ist 1,75 Meter groß.
Er wiegt 95 kg.
Ich habe die Ersatzgeschichte begonnen.
Die Schmerzen sind in den rechten Becken aus.
Der Patient beschreibt die Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzskala.
Er ist auf einer Schmerzskala.
Sie meinen, dass die Schmerzen in der Schmerzskala gelangt sind?
Ja, sie sind in der Schmerzskala.
Der Patient berichtet, dass diese Schmerzen bei Bewegung verstärken.
Der Patient hat keine Probleme mit dem Stuhlgang.
Heute hat der Patient wegen Schmerzen nicht gut schlafen.
Hat der Patient Parisen oder Lebungen in den Beinen?
Als Vorerkrankungen hat der Patient Bluthochdruck.
Der Patient nimmt regelmäßig für ihre Familie ein.
Der Patient hat 100 mg.
Er wurde als Kind operiert.
Der Patient ist bei der Patientin bekannt.
Der Patient ist Raucher mit 20 Päck.
Er trinkt geregentlich ein Glas Wasser Wein.
Der Vater des Patients ist wegen Herzimpfarkt mit 72 Jahre gestorben.
Der Patient hat ein Bruder.
Er war vom Beruf.
Der Patient ist Rennner.
Wie geht es jetzt weiter?
Ich frage mich, dass der Patient Schreibung vorfallt.
Ich werde genau untersuchen.
Was ist der Verdachstiagnose?
Ich vermute, dass der Patient Bandscheiber vorfallt.
Ich werde erst mal Lumbosakral Röntgen durchführen.
Warum werden Sie das durchschauen?
Ich kann nichts sehen.
Was für Differenzialdiagnosen denken Sie?
Der ist 66 Jahre alt.
Wenn er nicht schwer getragen hat, dann kann man das durchschauen.
Sie würden ein Röntgen durchführen.
Was würden Sie als nächste Untersuchung vorschlagen?
Ich würde untersuchen.
Sie haben gesagt, der Verdachstiagnose ist ein Bandscheiber.
Was würden Sie vorschlagen?
Ich würde das durchschauen.
Warum kann man nicht MRT machen?
Ich muss da fragen.
Das hat keine Trauma.
Das soll nicht die CT durchführen.
Aber die Qualität ist nicht gut.
Was ist Ihr nächstes Vorgehen?
Ich kann den Patienten chirurgische Therapie empfehlen.
Hat er eine Parise Nervenausfall?
Das erste, das man empfehlt, hat der Patient Schmerz.
Wenn Sie eine Symptomatische Therapie empfehlen,
dann kann man eine Operation diskutieren.
Das kann man empfehlen als konservative Maßnahme.
Was ist die Analyse für eine Analyse?
Das ist eine sehr romantische Art.
Das ist eine Art.
Dann vielleicht auch noch Opüte oder Novalgien und andere Schmerzen kombinieren.
Metamizol oder Novalmin-Sulfon oder die Marke.
Haben Sie noch eine Frage?
Ich glaube, die haben Sie heute nicht.
Ich glaube, der hat bis auf die Durchblutung alles gesagt.
Er hat gesagt, wir haben gesprochen über Parisien.
Hat er Parisien oder hat es gemeint?
Und Leben hat er nicht.
Ich möchte mit neurologischer Unterhaltung durchführen.
Ich möchte die Perifere durch Blutung, Motorik und Sensibilität untersuchen.
Ob das auch klinisch bestätigt.
Ich habe die Frage über Sturck.
Sie haben nicht gefragt, aber bei der Vorstellung haben Sie gesagt,
er hat keine Probleme.
Bei der Frage haben Sie nicht gefragt.
Es hätte bei einem Bandscheinvorfall auch eine Konzernentzsymptomatik haben können.
Wenn ich dauernd unterbrechen würde, dann würde die Konzentration,
das Gesamtbild, durcheinander werden.
Ich bin nicht gut in Grammatik.
Aber da waren einige grammatikalische Fehler.
Das kann man nachher hören, wenn man die Kacke hört.
Dann kann man selber gucken, bei Vorstellungen,
der Bruder ist gesund, nicht sei gesund, solche Sachen,
so Kleinigkeiten.
Aber das ist okay.
Ist das Ihre erste Vorstellung?
Ja, das ist meine zweite.
Das ist ein typisch deutscher Sprichwort.
Das ist nicht schlimm, das ist keine Prüfung.
Wir wollen hier lernen.